you sure oh i got a new show for you
with your uh
uh love doctor skit there's a show on
showtime called couples therapy
ooh it's good oh you'd like i love that
[ __ ] come on now
so this is like a [ __ ] she's like the
beast of all beasts therapist
and she sits down with all these uh
couples married couples
and there's like a bunch of them oh my
god it's fun it's so addicting there's
10 apples
it's on demand this b her
her this bees therapist she's been doing
it for like 30 years she
beats she's such a beast oh oh this two
lesbian couples fantastic
great so the so when they come in
and they have really it shows it over
like a span of like a year
of them start like they start they sit
down they say their problems
and then like say like you and i are
together
and you start talking like no it's not
like that i'm not allowed to do that
she's like nope
he gets to tell his version and then you
can go from there
oh like don't dictate what they say okay
so a guy jumped and she's like nope not
your turn
it's his turn oh great i live for this
[ __ ] no no it's
such a i live for this [ __ ] it's so good
oh [ __ ] and then how many sessions how
many sessions do you have with these
couples just like a bunch a bunch
yeah watch the show huh all right sasha
i don't know dude it's a [ __ ] show
why not i don't know that's a client's
privilege
you know it's privacy no they all sign
up for this oh they all sign up and
there's one company like dude just go
your separate ways
oh really damn it so it gets it gets
pretty good
oh man there there's one uh me and my
girl there's this one girl the black
couple
well he's black she's she's like puerto
rican or something
okay and uh she uh
doesn't want him like she's super
controlling he'll go to work she'll call
20 times
he's like [ __ ] i'm working really and
you know she was like she's super
controlling of him
oh and he's like like i can't go with my
friends i've been out with my friends in
five years
he's like because when i go out i drink
what the [ __ ] he said to me
well and then that's him right there
that's
so then the therapist asked the lady on
left she's like why why
why you want to control the narrative so
much what's going on there she's like
just i'm just i'm a very passionate
person like i'm you know i'm in the
driver's seat
but she's like well let's get to the bot
like why are you like this and then she
just tells her
relationship previous to that the dude
used to punch her in the face and like
[ __ ] her up
she's like i'm never gonna let that
happen again and then they start
untangling that really it's nuts
damn they get deep oh super deep oh my
god i'm in love with this [ __ ]
it's so good me and my girl gonna be all
over yeah i saw it it was like on uh my
yahoo news feed or something yeah
and then people were so addicting and i
got put let's see
how many seasons is it right now well
that's the first time it just came out
it's 10 10 episodes like if you have
dishes on demand they're all 10 episodes
check it out and then i watch that
takashi 6 9.
so you watched it just uh episode one
it's better than the hulu one better
than whoever
did it the real trade way leader on
there talking
oh yeah that's the only difference
though i think
they have a bunch of good people on
there talking about them it's cause on
the hulu dock they don't they only
really had his uh baby
mama yeah because she's on this too but
now she's like more mature
better looking and uh that leader of
trayway is pretty gangster
does she does she still feel pretty much
feel the same way about them oh yeah
they hate each other oh they hate each
other
you know she's the one who blames them
while their six-year-old daughter is
getting like
bullied online i mean i think everyone
blames him
for that yeah okay if your dad's a you
know pisa a troll
yeah we was watching this show me my
girl temptation island have you heard of
it
yeah oh my god my friends was on there
she was yeah she was on there is it like
love island bro it's so much better
it's it's trying to tell the americans
it's made for you so these couples they
volunteer
to like live separately on this island
and then they bring in their exes right
no no let's bring it they bring in
hot women hot men and they have to
choose which one like they want to go
like
they're involved when and go on dates
now they live separately they put them
in separate cabanas
and they look older you know what to do
one of my homegirls was on it she was
yeah girl that i cheered with for or
used to cheer with like i've known her
since like 2002.
she was on it like yeah she blew up from
it bro you can't see your at your girl
until the show is over like six or seven
are they bringing these bad yeah so
there's like
making making sure who where
that guy no i'm not on him i'm on season
three chin there's like some baddies on
there
and uh now we're they're thinking like
yo so they're
like you know our dues are we so we see
some new girls he's like yeah let's get
it
right so now the girl it takes a minute
for women to fall in love so there's
like they were nervous when dudes just
come it's a barrage of dudes just coming
in the house
now they're starting to open up and
they're starting to slowly fall in love
and the dudes are like man are we done
with these women we want our girls back
but they lost their girls you know what
i mean because they want to come on
there and just like [ __ ] [ __ ] that's
all they want to do
and then it was like yo they have to
decide at the end if they're going to
stay here
yeah they go to yeah and i'm basically
these women like some of them they just
and i'm over dating shows right now
like that i thought she was all about no
he yeah i wasn't wasting my time yeah i
realized how stupid it is it was like 50
episodes of [ __ ]
island love island's lit 50 60 episodes
you know how long that takes to go
through he went from super fan to
[ __ ] like what the [ __ ] is this
yeah yeah i was on season but i was i
like season five i think with tommy fury
then after that it's all down he fought
this weekend by the way
he won yep he won how about that when i
get off stage at the lap factory
right away you go bro i figured out what
you look like i'm like what this front
of a bunch of other comics i'm like what
you're like
you look like a rottweiler you gotta
[ __ ] together all you do
come on i'm just saying dude grab that
mic son